- [Narrator] Order up.
(crowd talking)
- [Customer] Can I have
a hot chocolate, please?
- Hot chocolate.
What's your name?
- Emily.
- [Narrator] Cafe Vine students
learn how to be efficient.
They learn how to be problem solvers.
They're very creative, and
they also learn confidence.
(coffee grinding)
These are things that will carry over
and help them in whatever
field they end up working.
- Mallory?
- Mallory again.
(bus driving)
- The vision of the school
is to provide students
with every opportunity
possible, open every door.
That means taking the
learning out of the classroom,
making it real, making it come alive,
so that we're really tapping into
every student's strengths.
- We've noticed that kids had an interest
to work with outside companies.
They were interested in entrepreneurship,
so the notion came up of
actually having a startup company
in the building.
- Cafe Vine is a student-run coffee shop
that serves students and teachers.
- Good morning, madam.
How may I help you?
- We thought that the
cafe would be a great
business model for the
high school students.
The kids see what it would be like
to have a real job and
what are some of the skills
that they need to take with them.
- Please sign.
- You learn time management.
You learn how to think on the spot.
You learn how to communicate very well.
- At first I thought it
was gonna be very easy
to do everything, but back
there with lots of people
behind the counter, it's really hard.
- All right, everyone,
how did this morning go?
The Cafe Vine elective
meets for an hour each day.
The students apply to the elective,
and it has to fit in with their schedule.
At the very start of class,
we talk about how the morning shift went.
How many people were doing bagels today?
- It was Kaitlin and Christian.
They were just kinda back and forth,
just hopping on other things
if we needed help, and that--
- I think first and foremost, we bond.
We know how to create a team.
"You have that, I have
this, let's work together."
I think that's a great
skill that we learn in Cafe.
- [Dana] During the
second half of elective,
they can do small group skill training.
- All the students will
get to do all the roles,
whether it's a prep or a barista
or a cash management.
- The attention to detail
that I learned in Cafe
has definitely made me a better student
in my academic classes
'cause you have to listen in Cafe.
You really have to make sure
you're getting every
single detail correct.
- [Narrator] You're gonna go
ahead and dip down once now.
We teach them the origin of the bean
and about the roaster.
Once this gets to about 350,
we're gonna start our roast.
We teach the kids
different colors and smells
and temperatures of each batch.
See what you smell in there,
and then write it down on the paper.
- [Dana] Cafe Vine students sell the beans
to different coffee shops locally.
- That was what really reeled me in,
was how to run a business.
It wasn't so much making
coffee or roasting beans.
It was more how does that operate?
- [Dana] One of the things
that we work on often
is inventory.
- [Narrator] Do we not
have the other cups?
There's 13--
- We can't just go
wasting supplies.
The cafe does have a budget
that you have to manage.
- [Dana] We also have a
scheduling app called Homebase.
- [Vincenzo] I have to
manage who works what day.
- We'll also talk about new ideas
or what to add onto the menu.
- [Dana] If there's
anything that looks like
we need to tweak it a little
in terms of the prices
or...
Okay.
- [Eli] For a lot of students,
it is their first real job,
so we give them the chance
to have that experience.
- The cafe does give us
some real, tangible skills
that we can apply to real world.
- That's 3.50.
- [Narrator] There's
something just really unique
and special about being
involved day-to-day
and to feel the rhythm of what it's like
to be in a startup.
- [Kaitlin] It definitely creates chaos,
but it's a good flow.
By the end of the shift, you feel good.
- [Narrator] Order up.
- I love it all (laughs).